these days we hear music all the time it
wakes us up motivates our workouts keeps
us company on our commutes doesn't
matter what kind of music it is music
itself has the ability to affect our
moods and our bodies in all sorts of
ways we not our heads we sway dance
music and give us chills even make us
cry music activates every area of the
brain that we have so far mapped in fact
there's no area of the brain that we
know about that music doesn't touch in
some way but what's behind all that
what exactly does music do to us to find
out I went to a whole series of tests
designed to measure my responses to
music met some kids whose brains may
actually be changing thanks for those
hours of learning practice and
performing spoke with a therapist who
used music to help former Congresswoman
Gabrielle Giffords learn to speak again
and got a glimpse inside the brain of a
two-time Grammy winning artist while he
played all to find out how music affects
us so what's going on when we listen to
music we visited the USC brain and
creativity Institute where I had my head
examined
literally to try to figure it out I'm
gonna go into this fMRI machine a tiny
tube will surround me we'll get a
baseline reading of my brain and then
I'm gonna listen to some music and we're
gonna see how my brain responds just
close your eyes relaxed and try and get
into the music as best you can okay and
here's what we saw these are scans of my
brain the areas in red are where my
activity is above average in blue below
average and as you can see there's red
activity all over my brain not just in
one specific area 25 years ago the idea
was that languages on the left side of
the brain and music is in the right side
of the brain but now that we've got
better quality tools higher resolution
neuroimaging and better experimental
methods we've discovered that's not at
all right how does that play out in
different regions of the brain when
music enters and then gets shuttled off
to different parts of the brain it stops
at specialized processing units in
auditory cortex they track loudness and
pitch
Tambor and things like that there's
visual cortex activation when you're
reading music as a musician or watching
music motor cortex when you're tapping
your feet snapping your fingers clapping
your hands the cerebellum which mediates
the emotional responses the memory
system in the hippocampus hearing a
familiar passage finding it somewhere in
your memory banks music is going on in
both halves of the brain the left and
the right the front in the back the
inside and the outside so what about a
musicians brain it's a play a piece of
music engages so many things motor
systems timing systems memory systems
hearing system there's all sorts of kind
of brain activity happening it's a very
robust thing to play music
I'm Alex Jacob Robertson I'm Nathan Glen
Robertson we ask these 11 year-old
musicians to tell us what's going
through their minds when they play some
of the most important things are having
good postures getting the note right
legato staccato for the violin you need
to hold your hand at the right place
then you need to have be in tune and
then you also have to have not only the
right intonation but the right sound and
then you also need to have great vibrato
there's a lot of things to think about
back at USC researchers have been
studying kids who play music over the
past five years to see how it affects
their development the multitasking areas
of their brains understandably lit up
but they've seen other results too music
training over the course of five years
has had benefits and cognitive skills
and decision-making also had some
benefits and for social behavior and
we've also seen changes in the
associated brain structures did you hear
that changes in brain structures they
found that the brains of children who
have studied music have stronger
connections between the right and left
hemispheres and that can make them
better more creative problem-solvers and
then there's a motion
you hear a piece like this
it's easy to understand why emotions
play such a big part in music this song
by Camille says song is known as the
music for the dying Swan in ballet and
while it might move ballerinas to dance
it inspires different reactions and
others
some people get goosebumps chills that
weird tingly sensation that you get when
a great piece of music just hits you in
the right way it's called for song and
not everyone gets it but it turns out I
do now we're gonna have you listened to
some pieces of music when you experience
a chill if you do I want you to just
press the spacebar so we have an
indication of when the sort of peak
moments of enjoyment are happening okay
Matt sax
a PhD candidate a USC wired me up to
measure my physiological response so
when I'm feeling that kind of emotional
connection that has a physical
manifestation we'll see what my body is
actually doing exactly
all right how was that that was that a
lot of them we got a wall now full
disclosure back in the day I believe the
cello which might have something to do
with why that particular song affected
me nice hair
but it turns out the brain doesn't work
here too we process the difference
between this pathway that connects the
auditory regions is on the side of the
brain here to the emotional region and
we show that the tract actually that
connects those two regions is stronger
more there's more fibers in that region
the people who get shows which means
some people's brains might have better
communication between what they hear and
how they feel the music itself also
plays a role in Forshaw sax uses
different songs in his lectures to see
if students get it I'll say raise your
hand when you get a chew and I'll play a
piece of music a classical piece and
maybe half the people will get it but
then he plays miss
the Rolling Stones give me shelter have
you ever seen the movie 20 feet from
stardom backup singers yeah there's a
part where they isolate the vocals from
Gimme Shelter and I played that at 94 7
people experience chills sort of
independent of where I go I have to tell
you bring that up made me think about it
and I got that little kind of thing at
the back of the back of my neck but why
would that happen the high-pitched notes
that she hit almost sounds like a scream
and it's very important and sestra Lee
for us to be able to pay attention to a
scream figure out what's going on and
either run or fight whatever we need to
do so how come that manifest is pleasure
well it's because our prefrontal cortex
the more rational thinking part of the
brain kicks in so you realize very
quickly after you have this really quick
startle reflex that there's nothing
actually threatening about the piece of
music that you're sitting in a safe
space with your headphones on and it's
in that reappraisal that we tend to
think of the pleasurable response is
emerging and whether you find listening
to music so pleasurable you get chills
or you absolutely despise a song it can
produce absolutely fascinating effects
in the brain
according to Levitan musically enjoy
triggers the brain's internal opioid
system yes
opioid system and just like the opioids
that come in pill form these chemicals
make you feel good and help you paint
and music you don't like well that
releases cortisol the notorious
stressful but that's not even the half
of what music can do in the brain you
turn on the when former Congresswoman
Gabrielle Giffords was shot in 2011 the
left side of her brain was severely
damaged leaving her struggling to speak
a condition called aphasia but to get an
idea of just how powerful musics effect
on the brain can be watch this video
[Music]
that word that she had been struggling
to say light came easily and song why
would she be able to sing a word when
she's unable to say it won't we know
about the brain is that the left
hemisphere controls language and there
are many other parts of the brain that
have music access music therapist
Meaghan Morrow's job is to help patients
use those other pathways to regain
language sometimes I compare it to being
in traffic and you can't move any
further but you might need to exit and
take a feeder road to get you to your
destination so music is basically like
that feeder road to the new destination
like a detour so we know that music can
help us relearn things like speech by
accessing alternative pathways in the
brain and learning to play music can
help strengthen brain connections but
what about making music
so me music is like it's the language of
humanity no matter where I go in the
world no matter if I'm played something
it doesn't matter if someone can't speak
the language and they're into it they're
intimately this is xavier de from Pallas
better-known is fantastic Negrito we
brought him the UCSF to meet Charles Lim
a neuroscientist who studies musical
creativity the Dufner is up next to
understand how fantastic Negrito his
brain works when he's making music dr.
Lim had him play one of his songs while
going through the fMRI so how did his
brain respond the areas that process
sensory and motor skills along with
sounds lit up you can see them here in
red and yellow makes sense right but
here's the really interesting part Lim
asked him to improvise to see what
happens when he's creating something
totally original
now watch what happens to his brain the
areas that were active before the ones
that deal with motor skills and sounds
are even more active but see how there's
way more blue in the front of his brain
that's the prefrontal cortex and its
associated with effortful planning and
conscious self-monitoring and it's blue
because it's less active we see that the
prefrontal cortex appears to be really
shutting down in these moments of high
creativity kind of like letting go of
these conscious self-censoring or
self-monitoring areas that normally are
there to help control that output and
Lim says it's about more than just
letting go you view it from perspective
of survival if human beings only could
do memorize rote responses we'd be long
gone it's not just the thing that
happens in clubs and in jazz jazz bars
it's actually maybe the most fundamental
form of what it means to be human to
come up with a new idea so music is so
much more than notes on a page it can
change the way we think and speak and
feel but is there a limit to what
science can tell us about music just
when I discover the answer to one thing
five new questions pop up that are more
interesting than the first and I've
gained an appreciation for how complex
the music making and music listening
system is it's not demystified for me at
all it's it's more mysterious than ever
love the little of the people
you
[Applause]